Щонайменше двадцятеро українських багатіїв
купили торік європейське громадянство.
Для цього вони скористались спецпрограмою Кіпру
для іноземців, що діє з 2013 року.
Вони вклали понад два мільйони євро у нерухомість
бо два з половиною мільйони євро у державні цінні папери
чи кіпрські компанії,
розповідає в ексклюзивному інтерв’ю Дойче Велле
одна з авторок матеріалу.
У списку з трьохсот прізвищ, що потрапив до журналістів,
українці посідають друге місце серед покупців громадянства Кіпру.
На першому - росіяни.
Більше ста росіян.
Це означає, що третина прізвищ у списку – росіяни.
Втім, автори розслідування впевнені –
реальні цифри набагато більші.
Їм вдалось отримати доступ лише до 300 прізвищ.
Тоді як, за даними Кіпрського уряду,  за чотири роки дії програми
паспорти придбали загалом тисяча триста людей.
Тобто, українців і росіян у цьому списку
може бути в рази більше.
Прізвищ багатіїв, які придбали паспорти,
журналісти не називають.
Вони готуються опублікувати їх самі найближчим часом.
Та деякі прізвища вже засвітились у їхніх статтях –
це українські бізнесмени Ігор Коломойський та Геннадій Боголюбов.
А також Костянтин Стеценко .
Серед українців є суперечливі постаті.
Хоч і не багато, але є.
Набагато більше суперечливих осіб серед росіян, які придбали громадянство.
Але це тому, що росіян у списку більше.
Найбільше авторів розслідування обурює те,
що влада Кіпру не особливо перевіряє кандидатів на громадянство.
І не переймається походженням грошей,
за які громадянство купується.
Хоча закон зобов’язує владу це робити.
Така ж ситуація і у Португалії,
де уряд за півмільйона євро
продає не громадянство, а "золоті візи" –
дозвіл на проживання і роботу щонайменше на 6 років.
І подальшу можливість подаватись на громадянство в цій країні.
Лише за минулий рік такою візою там обзавелись
десятеро українців і шістдесят росіян.
Якщо казати про громадянство ЄС, то офіційно його продають
лише Кіпр або Мальта.